hey what's up my name is Samuel Leeds
and in this video I'm going to show you
exactly how you can buy 10 houses with
just 50
000 pounds now you might be thinking if
I want to buy 10 houses with 50 000
pounds surely they're going to be really
cheap houses maybe in another country
five grand each or something crazy no
I'm talking about nice good condition
houses that you can rent out 10 of them
make a nice income and literally start
with just 50 000 pounds and if you
haven't even got 50 000 pounds it
doesn't matter because you can just get
a loan or you can get a silent partner
or a joint venture agreement or you can
borrow the money from somebody so once
you understand how to do this which I
want to show you right now you're going
to be absolutely aware this is how all
rich people invest in property what the
poor and middle class do is they work
really hard in a job
they try and save up money and then they
use that money after they've saved it up
for years and years and years to then
buy a house if you're doing that that's
your method then it's just going to be
too slow so
you're going to enjoy this video there's
gonna be a lot of content take good
notes and here goes the average house
right now in the UK is about 300 000
pounds now that means that if you're
going to buy an average house you're
gonna need 25
as a deposit that is how much if you're
buying a house to rent out which is
called a buy to let that's how much the
mortgage lenders demand so they put in
75 you put in 25 which is going to mean
you're going to need to put in 75
000 pounds as a deposit you're also
going to have to pay stamp Duty tax
which is going to be for a 300 grand
house you're probably talking around
about 10 000 pounds uh plus you're gonna
have to pay your legal fees maybe you
might have to get some new um carpets in
the house so realistically you're
talking about 90
000 pounds that you're gonna need to
save
to buy an average house and even if you
buy a cheaper house even if you say well
I'm going to find a house for a hundred
and fifty thousand pounds all right fine
you're still going to need half of 90.
still gonna need 45
000 pounds and with 45 000 pounds you're
only going to end up owning one house
I'm going to show you how you can get 10
nice houses so that
sucks that's old school that's what
losers do that's what people do that
don't understand the formulas that is
not how any rich people invest in
property this is how wealthy people
invest these are the formulas so you're
going to find a house
okay and you're going to go to an area
whereby you're going to do market
research on the street look at all the
houses in the street and see how much
they're selling for let's say the
average house in that street is selling
for 200 000 pounds which is very doable
200 000 pounds you're gonna find
I don't want that house I don't want
that house you're gonna find the houses
which are in really bad condition
they're really run down
now the great thing about finding houses
that are run down let's say it's got
structural problems the roof needs
fixing there's no kitchen no bathroom no
installation it's a wreck the great
thing about that is
firstly you can buy it really cheap it
might need let's say 50 000 pounds
spending on it but but secondly not only
can you buy cheap below market value but
no one else can buy that house and the
reason no one can buy that house that's
run down is because there's no mortgage
lender that will loan money on a house
that's in really bad condition they
won't do it you can't get a Residential
Mortgage you can't get a buyer because
you're not buying it to let it it's run
down you can't get any type of mortgage
so what that means is houses like this
that may be our probate Properties or
they're being they've been repossessed
and now they've been sold off cheap by
the Banks houses like this which exist
all over the place that are run down
they first-time buyers biceps landlords
can't buy it but the only people that
can buy these types of houses are cash
buyers so you can buy them cheap so
let's say you agreed to buy a house like
this it's really run down it's 50 000
pounds spending on it and you agree to
buy it for a hundred thousand pounds
which again is realistic it is 50
Instagram spending on it it is elbow
grease it needs three to six months
worth of work so what you do is here's
how you financially structure it you
can't get a mortgage on it you can't you
can't buy it cash because you've only
got 50 000 pounds so you're gonna get
something called a bridge
now a bridge is something that Bridges
the gap between you purchasing the house
and you then later getting a mortgage
because you can only get a mortgage or a
refinance on the house when it's in good
condition when it's mortgageable so you
buy it for 100 grand how much are
bridging companies going to loan you
well I know because I actually have my
own bridging Finance Company they're
going to typically loan you about 65
percent
of the purchase price and they will loan
you the money for the refurb so they're
going to give you 65 Grand that means
that you only need 35 Grand
okay plus your legal fees and stuff
maybe an extra 5 000 pounds Max so 40
000 pounds
to buy the house because you're going to
get a bridging loan that will pay the
rest you're going to get a bridging loan
that will pay the purchase a bridge and
loan company that will pay the the 50
000 pounds now of course you're gonna
have to pay the bridging loan company to
do this typically you're going to pay
one percent a month so if you've got the
money for six months let's say by the
way you're gonna pay zero stamp Duty on
this property because it's inhabitable
that's another little trick so let's say
you end up in tow with all your legal
fees and everything spending 50 000
pounds
which is the amount that I've said in
this video so you've got 50 Grand so
you're going to buy a house it's a
hundred grand house you're going to get
a bridging loan you're going to
refurbish it well then
once you finish the refurb the new value
of course is 200 000 pounds like all the
others in the street so what are you
going to do well you're then going to
get a re-mortgage
which means that you're going to then
get a buy to let lender a mortgage
company to come out look at the house
and they're going to say oh it's
beautiful it's in really good condition
of course it is you've just spent 50
Grand on it so it's got new carpets it's
fresh it's got a new roof and they're
gonna go okay cool and then they are
going to then
lend you
a hundred and fifty thousand pounds
which is 75 percent loan to value which
is the new value so they're going to
give you 150 Grand now what are you
going to do with that 150 Grand well
you're gonna for a start you're going to
pay off your bridging company
and you're gonna get your 50 Grand back
so effectively what you've done is
you've just recycled your money you
bought the house for a hundred you spent
50 on it you've now made 50 000 pounds
in equity in profit but instead of
selling the house you're refinancing it
you're getting that 50 000 pounds and
you're leaving that in the property as a
deposit when you get your 50 Grand back
what are you gonna do
it again
do it again do it again do it again and
keep recycling your money with the same
fifty thousand pounds until you're 50
000 pounds has bought you ten houses and
then you can tell me how right I was I
hope you enjoyed the video smash the
like button don't forget to share the
video around I'll see you guys next time
[Music]